RIKA GORN: Hi, my name is
Rika Gorn, and thank you
for coming to my talk,
"From Zero to Hero--
Best Practices for Setting
Up RStudio in the Cloud."
So last year, I was given the
keys to an incredible treasure.
And when I say keys, I
mean, literally keys.
I was handed three product
keys so that my data science
team at Spring
Health, where I work,
could start using RStudio
Server Pro, RStudio Connect,
and RStudio Package Manager.
Now my name is Rika Gorn,
and I'm a data scientist.
I'm not an engineer.
I work at an
incredible organization
called Spring Health.
We're a mental health
care tech startup
that provides a comprehensive
mental health care
solution to employers
all over the world.
Over the last year, we've been
growing and scaling a ton.
Sidenote, we are hiring.
And RStudio Team would be a huge
win for a very quickly growing
data science team.
So what does this mean
for me and my team?
Well, RStuido Server
Pro would allow
us to run R in a secure
remote environment,
and we wouldn't have to
rely on our local computer
for computationally
expensive jobs.
RStudio Connect would allow
us to publish all of our data
products, including Shiny apps.
R Markdown, dashboards, plumber
APIs, and quickly source them
to other departments.
And Package Manager would allow
us to centralize and manage
how our team uses internal
and external packages.
So needless to say, this is
an incredible win for my team,
and we were super
excited to get started.
But because of how
quickly everything
was moving, while I
was given the support
of a fantastic
engineer, the bulk
of setting up and configuring
RStudio Team would fall on me.
Now I'm very comfortable
coding in an R IDE
or working with R
Markdown documents,
but I didn't know anything
about servers or setting up
an infrastructure in the Cloud.
But I was pretty sure
that you couldn't code up
a server in an R
Markdown document.
So what did I do?
Well, of course, first
I went to Google.
Now RStudio has a ton of
great guides for administering
their products.
But since these are geared
for engineering or sysadmins,
I didn't even know where to put
all the code the guides were
talking about.
And so this was the
beginning of my journey
into the world of
data engineering.
As I started
learning, I realized
that there was a huge
disconnect between resources
available for engineers and
resources for data scientists
to learn engineering tasks.
I also learned that data
scientists, especially
in smaller organizations or
startups where engineering
support can be scarce,
desperately need access
to engineering
skills and resources
if they want to learn to quickly
deploy their own data products.
So, today what I
want to do is I want
to share with you my
own roadmap for how
to start the process of
learning data engineering.
So if you're looking
to set up RStudio Team,
then this talk should
be very helpful for you.
But even if your first
engineering product
includes a different server
setup, then most of this talk
should also apply
to you as well.
So my roadmap is framed
around three different parts.
People.
so how you can use
people around you
and your organization
to help you
set up your first
engineering project.
Learning.
So the most important
things for you
to learn as a data
scientist as you
go on your data engineering
journey and implementation.
What to do when you're
actually in the thick of things
in the weeds of your project.
OK.
So you're about to start your
first data engineering project.
What now?
So even if you're going
at this alone or as part
of a small group,
it's super helpful
to have an engineer
in your corner.
It's important to understand
that your relationship
shouldn't be combative.
I think as a data
scientist, very often,
you want all the data
possible at your fingertips.
Whereas engineers,
a lot of times,
they have particular
security concerns
or don't give you the
data that you need
as quickly as you may want it.
So it's important to
start a good relationship
with your engineer and to learn
from them what their security
concerns may be for your
server, and to understand where
their concerns are coming from.
It's also important
before you start
your project to
really understand
the value of your project.
Why are you doing this?
Who will benefit?
Who will use this new
server, this new product?
Are there people in
your organization
that you need to train or
to bring on into your side?
It's important to make sure that
there is kind of a pot of gold
at the end of your rainbow
because what you're
going to be doing is taking
time away from your regular data
science tasks and focusing
on a new skill set
on data engineering.
So it's important
that before you start,
the work that you're doing is
going to very clearly bring
value to you and to your team.
So technology and
learning, specifically
for engineering projects.
My biggest weakness when
I started in the beginning
was that I wasn't
comfortable using Bash.
For me, it was kind of scary,
black, blinking command line.
And I found a lot of
it very unintuitive.
There was one letter
commands and arguments
that were unintuitive
as compared to R.
So here we have on the
left hand side some R code.
And you can see, it reads very
easily, almost like a sentence.
You can see what's being
grouped, what's being counted.
Whereas the Bash on
the right hand side
can be kind of confusing.
There's one letter commands,
it's unclear what's happening.
So it's important
to start learning
a little bit about this.
You don't have to learn
everything, but start.
Learn how to move around
and your directories,
learn how to copy
and paste files,
learn how to log into your
server using something
called SSH protocols.
And make sure that you
actually have access
to the correct files.
And if you don't, learn
how to change the access
for your files using Bash.
Another piece of learning
that's important, take out--
it's important to draw out your
actual server architecture.
And what I mean when I
say draw it out, I mean,
actually take out a piece
of paper and draw it out.
It can even help to look at
AWS architecture diagrams
on the internet and try to
decipher what they mean.
AWS has a million
and a half services.
And as a data scientist
entering that world, a lot of it
can be super daunting
to understand.
And so understanding what
all the various terms,
all the different softwares and
products can be really helpful.
And that's why drawing out
your diagram, even if it's
super simple, can be helpful
in organizing your work
before you start.
Also, sharing that
diagram with your engineer
can also help you prevent
making errors in your system
before you even start.
So here's an example of a
simplified AWS architecture
diagram.
When you first start
drawing it out,
it's important to think about
which parts can actually
talk to each other?
What is public?
What is private?
And which parts of the
server point to what
other parts of the server?
So here, we have the VPC or
the virtual private cloud.
This is your virtual server
and it's hosted in AWS.
But you can also host
servers on Azure or Actable
or other managed services.
Here is where we have the meat
of what makes RStudio Team
RStudio Team.
We have three EC2 instances
or three smaller servers
that have all the data that make
up RStudio Server Pro, Connect,
and Package Manager.
So these EC2 instances
live in a private subnet,
which create a layer
of added security
so that random people can't
just access your server.
So here we have a bunch of
extra layers of security.
We have a load balancer, which
helps root the correct requests
to your servers.
We also have a
bastion or jump box,
which adds yet
another security layer
so that you don't jump directly
into the RStudio Server.
You have to go through an
added jump box in order
to get into your server.
Now once again, this
is a simplified model,
but it starts to show
you what AWS products
you, as the data engineer,
have to start setting up
in the cloud.
Now one last piece is another
important learning topic
that's critical before
you start your project.
And this is learning a little
bit about ports and security.
So this is a huge
topic, but it's
helpful to know just
a little bit about how
computers network and a little
bit about security management
and the most common internet
protocols that are used.
This is one of those
topics that engineers
seem to know a lot about.
But when I was
learning, I found there
weren't that many resources
available specifically
for data scientists.
So ports are
communication endpoints
that allow computers
to talk to each other
in various secure ways.
We have port 22, 25, 80, 443.
These are things like
HTTP, HTTPS, things
that you may have heard about.
But it's important to learn just
a little bit about what ports
are available,
which ones you can
turn on and off in your server.
SSL and TLS protocols
are protocols
that make secure
internet communication
possible by encrypting
internet traffic.
I like to think of
this as a handshake
between different computers.
Setting up these
protocols requires
learning a little bit about
different certificates
and configurations.
So it's important to
learn what protocol
you're going to be using
when setting up your project.
OK.
So you've done your
learning, and now it's
time for implementation.
My main piece of advice
is to get started.
Obviously, do your
research, but don't
fall into the trap of
analysis paralysis.
I think for me, as
a data scientist,
I kind of want to know
everything available
before I started.
But what happened is that
I did two weeks of research
and then realized I had
nothing to show for it
other than
theoretical knowledge.
So it's helpful here to take
a lesson from your engineering
teams and use a
more agile approach.
Where you get started
quickly you may fail quickly,
but then you can get started
again just as quickly.
All right.
So you've officially
started your project,
what do you do now?
So use your engineer as a guide
and to check in on your work.
They can tell you when you've
done something horribly wrong.
Like when I accidentally
opened all of my instances
to the entire world.
And they can also help
you to finish tasks
that you may not have
the appropriate security
clearances for.
So for example, if you
want to point your server
at a particular domain name,
they can help you to do that,
and they could also help you to
estimate costs for your server.
Learning.
So it's important to start
looking at the new data formats
and files that you're going
to be using in your server.
So to set up RStudio
Team specifically,
RStudio uses something called
the cloud formation template
to set up push-button
deployment.
Now when I started
looking at this,
I was very excited
because it looked
like something very similar
to something in the R world.
And that is that it looked
basically like a YAML file.
So it's important to
get to know these files.
Don't just deploy them, look
at them, read through them,
understand their defaults.
So when I started, I did
not look at the defaults
of my cloud formation file.
And then I had to
destroy my entire stack
and start from scratch
because I didn't change
a really important default.
So get to know your files,
get to know your file
formats, read through them,
understand their defaults.
So implementation.
You are going to
be making mistakes.
So make sure that you set
up guardrails and fail safes
for those potential mistakes.
First, take screenshots
of your instances.
This is something
that you can do in AWS
when you set up your server.
After you configure
server, you're
actually able to take
a screenshot of it.
So if you ever mess anything
up and you need to go back,
you don't have to start
over from scratch.
As you're going to be
setting up your server,
there's going to be lots of
passwords, PEM keys, .pk keys,
certificates.
Save all of these
in a secure way.
For example, saving them
in something like OnePass,
don't just save them
on your local computer.
And lastly, write
good documentation.
Write good documentation
that an engineer
can follow, that another
data scientist can follow.
Because at the moment,
while you're the admin,
you may not always be the
admin for this project.
So it's important to write good
documentation as you go along.
All right.
So your server is set up,
whether it's for RStudio Team
or for another project.
Now it's time for
the fun part, which
is to configure all of
your settings and defaults.
So when you're configuring
and after you've
set up the main
parts of your server,
you need to get buy-in from the
data scientists on your team
because they're going to
be the ones who are going
to be testing your deployment.
So it's helpful-- it was
helpful for me, at least,
to have a testing
log to write down
what deployment's are working,
which ones are failing.
And this is helpful for
later when I was actually
writing my documentation.
Understand who's
going to need to be
trained in the company
alongside your data scientists.
Don't bring everyone in
until you've figured out
most of the bugs.
You don't want to be doing
demos for your product
when there's still bugs in it.
So take time to set up
training and set up testing way
before you're going
to be introducing it
to folks at your company.
You don't want to discourage
your users and the consumers
of your product before they
can get started and get really
excited for your new project.
Set up time for
training and make sure
that there's a
little bit of time
before you actually
start demoing.
All right.
So once you've set
up your server,
you're now officially the
root user with sudo access.
It's important that you use
this power for good and not
for evil.
So learn about different
types of authorizations,
about Google OAuth, multifactor
authentication, API keys,
basic authorization.
As you're going to be
configuring your product,
you're going to need to be
giving folks in your company
access to it.
And this has to be done
in a secure manner.
Your engineer can
definitely help you here.
But knowing a little bit
about the differences
for different
authorization protocols
can be super duper helpful.
And once again, you may
be the root user now,
but you may not
be the root user later.
Implementation.
This is the fun part
for me especially.
Get inside your server
and play around.
Look at the important main file.
So for RStudio Pro, RStudio
Connect, and Package Manager,
I found that these
five files were
super duper important in
making sure that deployment
was actually working.
So when I first started, I had
a lot of deployment errors.
And that's because
I realized that I
hadn't changed some of the
defaults in these five files.
So get it into your
server, understand
what the paths are
like, understand
what the important
files are, understand
what their defaults are and
how they should be changed,
and if and when they
should be changed.
All right.
So this is my entire system for
setting up a data engineering
project as a data scientist.
So before you start,
partner with an engineer
and understand their
security concerns,
as well as the larger value
that your project brings
to the entire team.
Learn a little bit
about Bash, about ports,
and network administration,
and draw out
your AWS infrastructure
diagram on a piece of paper.
And when you're
ready to implement,
get started as soon as you can.
Throughout your project, use
your engineer as a guide.
Get comfortable with
different data formats
and set up guardrails
in case of failure.
Once you've set up your
project, take the time
to train your team
to test your project
and test out any
other little bugs
and issues that may come up.
Learn a little bit about user
authorization and root access.
And then most importantly,
get inside your server,
play around, and start changing
your defaults to your needs.
And finally,
remember to have fun.
Thank you so much for taking
the time to listen to this talk.
I look forward to
answering your questions
and connecting over the
rest of this conference.
Thank you so much to
everyone at RStudio
and everyone at Spring Health
who helped me with this talk.